top story this hour police in South
Africa have arrested the Most Wanted
fugitive in the 1994 Rwandan Genocide
after more than 20 years on the Run
Fuller Johnson is accused of organizing
the killing of nearly 2 000 Tutsis who
were seeking shelter in a Catholic
Church
let's get more on this now from Al
jazeera's Catherine soy she joins us
from Nairobi Catherine first of all what
more do we know about this arrest after
years on the Run
was arrested
on Wednesday I'm following a joint
operation with security forces in South
Africa he's expected to be arraigned in
court on Friday he has been on the run
for many years he has been going around
South African countries trying to evade
a risk and you know why we're here is
because he is one of the masterminds of
the London genocide and what he is being
accused of is that he participated in a
massacre of 2 000 people in a church he
said to have been the one who bought
fuel to burn down the church and to uh
bring down the church buildings and
during that time all that time you know
we're talking about 2 000 people
children
um you know and and also elderly women
all trying to save themselves and and
basically what happened is that they had
no way to get out so they uh basically
was just helpless and this man and
others participated in that uh not a
massacre and we also know that uh the
the priest who was in charge of that uh
Catholic Church is in jail he will also
he was also involved so he's in jail now
a Catherine Mort's system of justice is
in place for perpetrators like Kashima
well you know the government has
the many people people have already been
arrested they have have been convicted
in Rwanda itself we also have their
criminal cream
ICC caught uh in The Hague that has also
uh is you know investigating some of the
people including a mastermind who was
arrested with Elise also in jail uh
facing those criminal charges but you
know what happened uh in Rwanda is you
know something a lot of people
especially the survivors say that they
want to see Justice they want uh justice
for their loved ones people who survived
as well we also know that several other
masterminds are still on the run the
government says that they are going to
do it's going to do whatever it can to
make sure that Justice is is is found
okay Catherine soy thanks very much for
joining us there with the latest from
Nairobi